[Music]
all right what's up
mkbhd here in the new crispy shirt
and well today was apple's new october
fall event the new iphone event whatever
you want to call it
but of course since it's 2020 it was a
virtual event nobody actually went down
to apple headquarters to see the new
iphones
instead we got the pre-recorded apple
announcement video so that means instead
of the event ending and then everybody
going over to the hands-on area to check
out and play with the new stuff
that's obviously not happening right now
but i still have a lot of thoughts
and reactions to to what they just
showed what they just unveiled
so this video is sort of everything you
need to know and
my honest take on it so it's really two
new things
homepod mini and the new iphones but
let's hit let's do homepod mini first so
you may or may not remember when i
reviewed the original homepod
apple's smart speaker back when it came
out in 2018 i called it
the dumbest smart speaker mainly because
it's just siri powering this thing
and there's no screen and it was pretty
rough homepod mini which is new
is 99 bucks and it's basically a much
smaller version
of the homepod again so meaning no
display
just the glowing set of volume controls
and the touchpad up at the top
and it will still focus very heavily on
audio quality
and just being a good speaker so there's
an s5 chip inside specifically for
computational audio so it's listening to
where it is in your environment and
sounding as best as it can
it still has forced cancelling woofers
still has a bunch of tweeters and all
that stuff it's just
way smaller now but you know sound
quality is one of those things where i
you got to hear it i could actually hear
it to believe it so
the homepod was a pretty good sounding
speaker i just i gotta get the actual
homepod mini
in the studio to test that for myself
but other than that
yeah it's a it's a smart speaker still
powered by siri there's also an ultra
wideband chip in there for better direct
control
from an iphone and there's also this
kind of cool intercom feature so if you
have a family of people using
connected apple devices they can all
hear your intercom message
on the homepod and also there's a note
in there about siri knows like
20 times more facts i think that's what
they said
which great i guess but
you know it's i've been using siri it's
it's still siri
but anyway yeah homepod mini 99 bucks
which
kind of sits in there it's cheaper of
course than the regular homepod but
in this world of all the other smart
speakers where you got google home smart
speakers you got the alexa smart
speakers
and all shapes and sizes some of them
have screens some of them have clocks
it's like you gotta really want siri
or that ecosystem plug-in to pick the
homepod
over those so okay then we got to the
new iphones
so iphone 12 mini iphone 12
iphone 12 pro and iphone 12 pro
max so four new iphones and there's a
lot of really cool stuff in here i gotta
be honest i like a lot of what they
showed
in fact i think a lot of iphone 12 is so
good that it makes the 12 pro a little
bit less
like a convincing buy for me maybe let
me know if you feel the same way but
really first of all the big overarching
headliner feature for all these new
iphones
is 5g they all have it they spent what
felt like a million years talking about
it they went over the faster data speeds
the higher capacity how it's the future
you know they had verizon come up on
stage to say all this great stuff about
it so
here's what i'll say about 5g all right
it's a two-sided thing uh right now
not really ready yet like most people
don't have 5g coverage whether it's the
device they're on or the network they're
on it's just not out there yet i did a
whole video on 5g explained about why
it's not out there
first link below the like button if you
want to check it out but the bottom line
is
you probably don't have 5g yet the
coverage isn't really there the
infrastructure just isn't really
built yet so you're not really buying a
phone right now because it has 5g
but but
people keep iphones for probably the
longest amount of time of any new phone
so people are going to have this new
iphone in
three four five years and in five years
there's a better chance that 5g will be
more built out and maybe you'd regret
not having 5g
in five years so it's a good thing that
all the new iphones have 5g so you don't
have to pick the one that does or
doesn't have it
they all have 5g so okay first up iphone
12. and the new design to me
is pretty sweet it's the new flat sided
shape that i was waiting for
like ipad pro it's got the aluminum
frame all the way around
flat screen and of course some new
antenna action positioning it well for
5g
there's ip68 water resistance and
there's a new
ceramic shield specialized glass
on the front ceramic shield it's an
interesting
branding of a new glass features apple
didn't even really want to call it glass
it's a new composite material with
crystallization and they didn't actually
call it glass at any point on stage
but what you should know is it's
offering four times better
drop protection that's the main
headlining feature
now of course there's gonna be people
going out and testing this
it's hard to quantify what is four times
better do you
drop it and it breaks a quarter of the
time that it usually would i don't
really know
i'm just hoping it translates to better
scratch protection but i think they're
talking about shadow resistance
either way there's going to be drop
tests on youtube in a couple weeks
hopefully it's stronger glass so the
three big new things they talked about
on the iphone 12
phone itself are the screen charging
and the cameras so the screen is now
much better
it goes from that 720p lcd screen we all
kind of like talking about on iphone 11
to now it's a 6.1 inch
1080p oled display with thinner bezels
it's a significantly better screen than
on iphone 11 and of course i'm happy to
see this
better brightness much more contrast in
an oled
better pixel density the whole thing the
notch doesn't go away as you can tell
obviously but
that might be the only downside it's a
hdr10 certified
it's flat right up to the edges the
whole thing is nice
the new cameras are also pretty nice
it's a new dual 12 megapixel camera
system so they didn't change the numbers
here
but it is a new ultra wide and a new
standard camera with an f 1.6
aperture and that should make for better
low light and
portrait shot performance but you know
most of the smartphone
camera improvements that you get in 2020
nowadays are with software
and so you're going to see stuff like
that with their new smart hdr 3
with night mode coming to the
front-facing camera that's pretty sweet
so all the stuff combined should make a
better camera system in iphone 12 but
i'm definitely gonna have to be testing
that for the full review as well so then
when i say new charging
i don't mean usb-c which would have been
nice but what i do mean
is the new magnets built into the back
of the phone because
magsafe is back
this to me this is the coolest new
thing in the iphone to be totally honest
i guess i'm so used to so you know how
there's a
an apple watch charger where you just
connect it with magnets it lines it up
slap it on charges the watch well now
there's going to be a magsafe
big wireless charger that slaps on the
back of the phone helps you align it
perfectly every time
and charges the phone it's not wireless
there's still a wire but like now you
maybe maybe
you can kind of still use the phone
while it's charging that way
this is this is the part where it would
be nice to have a hands-on
because then i could see like how strong
the magnets really are and if they
really firmly connect to the back of the
phone and all that stuff
but i don't know i think magsafe being
back is sweet i checked the apple store
it's already up actually
39 bucks for the iphone 12 magsafe
charger
not insane but not cheap obviously but
it's at least it's not a hundred bucks
or something stupid it'll charge at 15
watts
so a normal 2020 wireless charging speed
nothing too crazy
so i'm into that but not just for the
charging part but also for the entire
ecosystem of mag safe accessories that
are born from this magnet and a lot of
these are also already up in the apple
store
you know there's now this little wallet
that magnetizes to the back of the phone
now
there's some mag safe cases and magsafe
is stackable
so it'll charge through the case too a
lot of cool stuff just snapping onto the
back of the phone and i imagine there
will be
way more third-party mag safe
accessories that come out
as soon as this phone drops which could
be cool for other chargers and other
cases and things like that other
accessories for the iphone
uh yeah there's gonna be a lot of stuff
snapping on the back of the iphone
also it's probably gonna get a lot of
people really used to snapping things on
the back of the iphone
and not wanting to plug in any more
hot take next iphone won't have a plug
because everyone's gonna be so used to
snapping it on the
on the back it's not a good take it's
just a hot take also speaking of
charging
there is officially now no charging
brick
in any of the iphone boxes starting with
iphone 12
which again sounds crazy but we also
called it there's a whole video again
that i did i'll link below
just about this and i kind of called it
pretty much exactly the way they did it
in this event they talked about it in
the environmental section of the keynote
you know all the environmental e-waste
savings and all that stuff
they showed us a new smaller iphone box
which saves space and shipping now that
volume is smaller
that's more efficient you can watch that
whole video below if you want to see it
more in-depth analysis or ranting on on
what that means for the iphone's box and
the rest of the industry
but yeah iphone now will just come with
the phone itself
and a single usbc to lightning cable and
the paperwork
and that's it there's of course all the
new usual year-over-year iphone
improvements here with the iphone 12
there's new colors blue red black
white and green i'm personally feeling
that blue and the red since phones are
still pretty shiny here from what i can
tell
and there's a new chip as well a14
bionic which is the first five nanometer
chip
in any phone six core cpu four core gpu
better machine learning performance and
image processing etc etc this is no
surprise apple's been
really good at chips not to take
anything for granted but yeah this is
gonna be a
pretty fast phone for a long time so
that's iphone 12 right
that phone is going to be 7.99 and then
real quick
they also dramatically unveiled a
smaller
iphone 12 mini and it comes out like a
month later in the year but basically
the iphone 12
mini is just a smaller version of
everything we just saw that's new in the
iphone 12
mag safe new colors all that stuff but
just
smaller and a 5.4 inch display and that
phone iphone 12 mini is going to be 6.99
so the price of the standard iphone
did just go up technically but they
brought in
so they made a new mini version to fill
in that price gap
and they still have the se so they still
have a whole lineup of phones ranging
from a bunch of different prices but i'm
very curious about this mini
and getting my hands on it and just how
small it'll feel on the hand and if
there's any reason to get it
over the regular 12. but of course that
leads us to the big dogs you see here
iphone 12 pro and iphone 12 pro
max now there's actually not that much
in my opinion different about the pros
this year versus the 12.
so the prices are still the same 999 and
1099 both starting at 128 gigs but the
main more subtle differences here are
the size the colors and the cameras
so not a drastic stuff but that's what's
new so again it packs all the good stuff
from the 12 that we just talked about
ip68 water resistance the ceramic shield
the a14 bionic the magsafe magnets
and now it's just in a body with
slightly larger displays than the last
year
6.1 inch and 6.7 inch oleds
and you're getting flat stainless steel
sides now instead of aluminum
which is incredibly shiny and uh the new
colors here are white black
blue and gold and i swear to you that
gold looks
i guess i'd say better than anything the
escobar brand could have cooked up so
well done apple it's a flashy phone and
then basically if you're looking for the
real reason to buy the pros
look no further than those camera
modules that's where the big new stuff
is
so it's still triple cameras but it's an
all new hardware stack so a new standard
and ultra wide and telephoto camera both
the pros have deep fusion
on all four cameras including the
front-facing camera
and you also now do get that lidar
sensor back there which we first saw in
the ipad pro earlier this year
and it should help with not just better
and more accurate ar
but also improved autofocus in the dark
which is sweet honestly lidar to me
seems more useful more often
on an iphone where you take a lot of
photos in low light than an ipad
so it's kind of funny that we got it on
the ipad first but lidar is on the
iphone now there's also this new
pro raw image format that they talked
briefly about and it looked really cool
but then
when you look up the specs of the iphone
on their site it says
coming soon which is what they said
about deep fusion for months before it
actually came out
so i'm going to hold my judgment on this
pro
raw image format until it is actually
out and then curiously
slightly different cameras on the 12 pro
and 12 pro max so 2.5 x telephoto
on the 12 pro max and 2x telephoto
on the 12 pro slight difference there
it's not like 100x zoom or anything
crazy but
that is different and then the 12 pro
max has a better
sensor shift optical image stabilization
while all the others
have it built into the lens like it
always has been so really the max
has all the highest end features and
then probably their biggest
flex in the camera module of them all
was the pros
10 bit dolby vision hdr
4k 60 fps video just insane it's the
only camera in the world that'll shoot
dolby vision when it comes out
and again having a new standard like
this where this is the only camera in
the world that'll do it doesn't really
lend itself to any reputation for that
standard
so if it's a good camera we'll all think
good things about dolby vision but yeah
i don't know how good that's going to be
yet but i'm excited to actually see it
and so that
is basically it for what's new with the
pros
now you might have noticed there's a one
thing missing
at least one thing i was kind of hoping
for which is promotion
high refresh rate 120 hertz that is not
in these new iphones it's not in the
iphone 12 pro or 12 pro max
now if you're if you're defending apple
of course you're saying oh whatever it's
not a big deal the average person wasn't
really going to notice that which i
guess
okay fine you're technically you're
right if you're just going to defend
them no matter what then yes
they made the right choice no one was
going to notice that
but also apple is notorious for doing
that extra next level of stuff that the
average person probably won't notice
like 10 bit 4k 60fps dolby vision hdr
video
and all kinds of stuff like the
calibration in their displays so i'm
also
a little bummed that they don't have
promotion here because to me
the person with a thousand dollars to
spend on a phone and i want to really be
convinced by this phone over
you know another android phone i could
buy uh
to that specific customer who's going to
appreciate 10 bit
4k hdr uh i would appreciate high
refresh rate too but whatever the reason
is whether it's the yields not being
high enough for that display quality or
they just couldn't get them in that
volume at all whatever the reason
it's not here fingers crossed maybe for
next year then a couple other small
notes
we see those uh notches still on all the
new iphones they appear to all be
the same size and shape as before they
didn't mention face id once on stage so
i'm just going to go ahead and assume
there are no improvements to face id
same sensors up there
uh yeah same face id then for 5g they
talked about a
smart data mode on the iphone which
intelligently only uses the 5g radios
when they're needed which to me kind of
sounds a little bit like
we only have high refresh rate on the
ipad pro
when it's needed meaning not all the
time but i'm
super curious when they turn on 5g and
when they don't will it be off most of
the time to save battery
5g is a big battery hit very interested
in testing the iphone and seeing when
that turns on and then yes that
mysterious little rectangular cutout on
the side of the iphones that we've seen
all the way from the models
all the way to the renders in the
keynote that is the 5g antenna cutout
four millimeter wave officially so
that's it i don't really have any other
impressions of like the
the materials and the new sizes and how
big the mini is versus the max and
the colors and all that stuff because we
don't have them so that'll be
a separate video when we actually do get
them here in the studio and
i can check them out and deliver that to
you guys so make sure you subscribe
to be among the first to see it when it
does come out but let me know what you
think
which one of these four new iphones
speaks to you the most
i'm kind of probably still gonna go for
the max anyway either way
thanks for watching enjoy the rest of
techtober a lot more videos coming up
soon
see you guys later so big shout out to
expressvpn for sponsoring
this video so have you ever gone to
search for a show on netflix
and seen this see netflix probably has a
show you want it's just restricted so
depending on where you live
netflix and other services have
different content for different places
so you're paying a full subscription but
you're only getting access to
technically
a fraction of the total shows and movies
they have
but with expressvpn i can just change my
location to anywhere in the world
and basically unlock thousands of movies
and tv shows so
if you go and look online it tells me
exactly which country to connect to to
be able to watch certain things
so if the dark knight's not on netflix
boom now i'm in canada
now i can watch it maybe i want to watch
inception just like that now i'm in the
uk
watching it so i've watched movies i
didn't even realize i didn't have access
to and on top of all that expressvpn is
super fast
with never any buffering or reduced
quality so yeah expressvpn it's one of
those things
i genuinely use all the time it keeps my
data protected
and gives me full access to all the
subscription services that i pay for so
if you want to give it a shot yourself
which you probably do
you can get three months for free by
visiting expresscpn.com
mkbhd thanks again to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video
thanks for watching catch you guys the
next one
peace